uh let's bring you some breaking news on
sky news we're just hearing that owen
patterson the conservative mp uh a name
you'll be very familiar with over the
last 24 hours he's been embroiled in
this row over mp and standards uh owen
patterson found guilty of lobbying
essentially and uh
mps voted yesterday on whether to
suspend him for 30 days and whether to
overhaul
the body that oversees
the actions of mps and the standards
they uphold in parliament
he has just resigned owen patterson has
decided to resign as the mp for north
shropshire saying i will remain a public
servant but outside the cruel
world
of politics this follows a government
u-turn today over that vote yesterday an
emergency debate taking place on monday
and a new vote as well but ahead of that
owen patterson has resigned let's bring
our deputy political editor
sam coats to react to this uh owen
patterson saying it is a cruel world uh
politics and he's leaving it
patterson who of course was found to
have broken
the rules on paid lobbying just last
week and was now after that government
u-turn facing 30 days suspension from
the house of commons and bluntly likely
a by-election he has circumvented that
in the last few moments by announcing
that he is going to resign uh with
immediate effect and that means that he
will no longer be facing uh the
humiliating vote in the next few days uh
and will uh stand down uh without uh the
prospect of uh the people of his
shropshire constituency having to work
out whether he faces a by-election or
not uh owen patterson who i spoke to
yesterday had been delighted
at the way that the government had
appeared for a brief period of time to
come to his aid he thanked boris johnson
and jacob rees-mogg to me
saying that he was grateful that they
stepped in to
for that brief period of time before
this morning's u-turn junk the entire
system uh of policing mps which had
found him guilty
and offered to uh basically start a uh
create a new one which uh he thought and
hoped would be fairer and might come to
a different outcome but there was such a
massive backlash overnight including
from uh conservative mps that uh boris
johnson
u-turned this morning uh and decided
that he did need to face another uh vote
in the house of commons which to be
honest downing street everyone else
expected would be passed by a majority
of mps which would have seen him uh seen
him
uh suspended and possibly uh face his
local constituents it has been a very
bruising period for him but the contents
of the parliamentary commissioner for
standards report uh was absolutely
damning it found that on a number of
occasions uh he had made approaches to
government officials being in the
department of health or be there in the
food standards agency to push
the commercial agenda of companies to
companies uh that together paid him over
a hundred thousand pounds a year on top
of his parliamentary salary uh i asked
him what do these companies think that
they were going to get for their money
for their hundred thousand pounds a year
he said you just have to ask them i just
provide them with the occasional insight
insisting that he had acted properly at
all times but that was not what
catherine stone the parliamentary
commissioner for standards found she
found that the way that
he
had
approached these different government
departments breached the rules quite
clearly on multiple occasions over a
long
time span that report came out last
tuesday the day before the budget and
since then paterson mounted a huge
campaign using allies both in parliament
like david davis in the media like
charles moore who did it with the prime
minister on tuesday night
and
ultimately danny street decided to take
his side but that proved to be
incredibly unpopular you had mps
complaining of their offices vandalized
overnight
peter bone uh mentioning in the house
comments this morning he voted uh to
junk the standard system and save owen
patterson uh he said that there was
graffiti on the outside of his
constituency office this morning as a
result of that decision
the standard system the policing system
for mps um in also in chaos with no
prospect of quite what was no certainty
of what was going to replace uh that so
another problem because there were lots
of mps far from paragons of virtue uh
some of whom in uni
under investigation uh right now uh and
there was no real sense of how the
government was going to get out of that
deadlock until shortly before 11 o'clock
this morning when jacob bruce bogg uh
announced uh the u-turn on behalf of
boris johnson uh now uh this means that
there will no now no longer have to be a
vote on uh owen patterson's conduct uh
in the next few days it was likely on
monday uh because uh he's standing down
uh there will however certainly be a
by-election in the seat it's a pretty
safe
conservative scene